[Music]
these creatures
[Music]
what's up everyone it's Warren and as
you just saw we have some pretty big
spider-man far from home news to talk
about today it seems like every day now
we get some sort of new information a
new TV spot or a leak for spider-man far
from home and leave it to good old Tom
Holland to drop the spoilers and he
dropped a pretty big spoiler and as you
can see in the video after he said it
everybody kind of started freaking out
that he just said that so I'll break
down what this means why everybody was
freaking out and why was such a big deal
but real quick if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe I'm doing a
giveaway at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers I will be picking
three winners and each will get to
choose one item from the Marvel Legends
series collection so be sure to
subscribe and like the video now the
first part in what Tom Hollands says is
that him and Mysterio are best friends
in the movie I've talked a lot about
this in my spider-man far from home
videos despite what the cast and the
trailers would have you believe Mysterio
is the villain of this movie he's just
trying to trick Peter into thinking that
they're really close so he can turn on
him and take his place as the hero that
everybody loves
but then he drops that bomb about the
elementals actually not being from the
main universe now as we learned and saw
in the spider-man far from home official
trailer Mysterio is actually not from
the earth-616 or main MCU universe he
said that the snap tore a hole in his
dimension and that he comes from a
different universe now again all of the
cast members and the trailers and TV
spots are making it look like Mysterio
is this really good guy who's come to
help them fight the elementals but Tom
Holland just told us that the elementals
are from a different universe as well so
this basically confirms that Mysterio is
commanding and controlling these
elementals if they are not his illusions
and their actual beans they are
definitely under his control because
this is exactly what Mysterio does he's
a trickster he's an illusionist he's
basically a master liar and the
elementos causing destruction to the
world and then Mysterio showing up the
fight them that is all part of his plan
and illusion remember Mysterio wants to
be the hero that everybody loves he
wants to be the next Iron Man so he is
setting up these elementals attacking
every
buddy so he can come in and defeat them
and be the hero and Tom haulin letting
that spoiler loose that the elementals
are from the other universe that
Mysterio is from as well pretty much all
but confirms this and something else
that this does confirm is that there is
in fact a multiverse a lot of people
were questioning whether or not Mysterio
was lying about being from another
universe but Tom Holland just revealed
that the multiverse is real and when
Thanos snapped his fingers it created a
dimensional rift and that is how
Mysterio and the elementals went from
their universe into the main universe so
this is big news moving forward but the
MCU this opens up the MCU to so many
different possibilities and
opportunities with many many different
characters and stories Tom Holland the
king of spoilers revealing to us that
the elementals come from another
universe just like Mysterio pretty much
confirming that Mysterio fighting these
elementals trying to look like a hero is
just an illusion that he is putting on
this is something that myself and many
other people have been expecting since
we got the first spider-man far from
home teaser trailer so let me know what
you think about this big news that Tom
Holland just dropped do you think that
Mysterio really is the villain and he is
controlling the elementals or do you
actually think Mysterio is good let me
know your thoughts in the comments down
below and again a reminder about my
giveaway when I hit 450,000 subscribers
I will be picking 3 winners and each
will get to choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection and
I'll be starting giveaways on Instagram
and Twitter as well if you want to
follow me on social media as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very Nass and
all it took
you said it cost you everything while
crying like a baby now your